I want to continue our conversation
though about voter suppression and now
focus in so earlier I spoke first about
absentee ballots being rejected at
abnormally high rates in some places I
want to now dial in and focus on the
voter purges because we've had a bunch
of different systems in various states
across the country pulling people off of
the voter rolls D registering people and
a common tactic for D registrations is
to target for Democratic
disproportionately minority areas
because those groups tend to vote more
democratic in the application of a D
registration standards so you can very
easily say listen we are establishing an
unbiased system that simply says for
example if you've not voted in six years
you're going to be D registered doesn't
have anything to do with race doesn't
have anything to do with Democrats
whatever but then you can choose to run
that system only through certain
counties voter registration system so
you can still pick and choose where you
apply that and we have what I guess is
good news even though I worry it's too
little too late out of Ohio which is the
federal judges yesterday ordered that
Ohio voters who had been purged because
they hadn't voted in six years must be
read to the voter rolls and allowed to
vote if they want to these are all
emergencies okay and so an emergency
motion was granted to a variety of
voting rights groups to overturn the
ruling which said that the purging of
those Ohio voters was totally legal the
voting rights groups accurately
correctly made the case that a lot of
these races are tight and that just by
pushing people off the voter rolls you
could actually flip the results of the
election obviously and the really
important point to understand here is
why do they claim that it makes sense to
remove people for from voter rolls
because just removing someone from voter
rolls because they haven't voted whether
it's legal or not is a different
question and what is it that you're
trying to achieve by doing that the
right claims
that the reason to pull people who
haven't voted for six years off of voter
rolls includes
a combination of number one there are
people who are double registered so they
haven't voted in that place for six
years because they're registered and
voting in some other place and we
shouldn't have those double
registrations some people have died and
that's why they haven't voted for six
years and thus they should be removed
from the voter rolls and that you could
have people trying to vote in two places
you could have people showing up and
saying I'm this person who's actually
dead and voting for them it's all in
person voter fraud possibilities but
that's the key word possibilities and
that's why pat double registrations are
dead people on the rolls they're not
problems in and of themselves unless you
actually have a string of people trying
to cast double votes voting twice voting
for dead people there's no evidence of
that
I've been registered in two places for
pretty significant periods of time but
I've never attempted to vote in both
places and to my knowledge based on the
records I've seen no one has shown up at
one of the places I'm registered and
tried to vote as me so the mere
possibility of that happening is not
actually a good reason to say let's pull
these people off the voter rolls and
there certainly are better solutions to
this than just making it so that if you
haven't voted for in six years you're
just automatically off of the registry
one way to do it would be like how we
have here in Massachusetts I recently
moved and I've made it so that I put in
my old address as well so they would
kick me off of the last place where I
was registered and I'm only registered
in the in the new place that I live so
that's one way to do it I guess with
regards to if people have died what you
can do there is make the deficit for
death certificate known to the people
running the polling booths so that
automatically you're taking off I think
there are just other solutions to this
than purging everyone absolutely and
there there are solutions that some
states as you point out have already put
in place and by the way the anecdotal
cases of actual in-person voter fraud
are almost exclusively Republicans
trying to prove some kind of political
point about how easy it is to vote
illegally
and then they get caught and it turns
out it's actually not so easy so good
news from Ohio that these voters are
being allowed back in same needs to
happen in Georgia before it's too late
and before you know it Trump's gonna
order another 15,000 troops to the
border before people realize that this
is actually what's going on in terms of
voter disenfranchisement and this is all
about the new Jim Crow Republicans have
pioneered what are really clever I mean
I kind of hesitate to use that because
it sounds almost positive but these are
pretty clever ways to reduce the turnout
or the actual number of Democrats who
end up voting they use the farce of
voter fraud to justify these measures
it's meant to help Republicans win and
it has helped them win it's a great
strategy for them the one good thing if
there's anything in this that I can
point to is that the early voting
numbers and that the voter registration
numbers that we've seen in some places
are really really high and we're not
going to have to wait that much longer
to get the results as I've said if you
have experienced any of these
difficulties in voting please let us
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show and
we will be talking about this up to and
including on Election Day today's
program was made possible in part by
Blink esteem / Pakman I love bling cast
it's the really perfect app for anybody
who likes politics and learning and if
you're watching or listening to the
David Pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
studs is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15 minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blinka
sconces
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t-dot-com
slash PA k ma n to sign up